How do you measure electricity before you've
invented the voltammeter?
How about with a frog?
This was Michael Faraday's solution to testing
electrical circuits back in the 1820s,
before more sophisticated methods had hopped
along.
Down in the basement of the Royal institution,
Faraday and his mentor, Humphry Davy,
kept a well stocked froggery, jumping with
healthy frogs.
On the occasion that electrical equipment
or circuits needed testing,
they would select a willing participant, hold
it by the legs and smash its head in to render
it, well, dead.
"We are joined together today to celebrate
and commemorate the life of Sir Albert 'Hoppy'
Frogbert III - who gave his life valiantly
in the name of science..."
Repeating experiments conceived by Luigi Galvani
in 1780,
a thin metal plate was then positioned underneath
each leg muscle, and wired up.
If the circuit was live, the legs would twitch.
Lucky for the frogs, Faraday invented his
voltammeter in 1833,
a device that quantified electrical charge
as it passed electricity through chemical
compounds and measured the gas given off.
Today this wooden panel is all that remains
of Faraday's froggery.
Apart for the ghosts that is...
they've haunted the halls of the Royal Institution
ever since.